>> MORE GRAY THAN BLACK AND
WHITE.
JOINING ME NOW, CLAY TRAVIS, FOX
SPORTS HOST, RADIO HOST, AUTHOR
OF THE BOOK, REPUBLICANS BUY
SNEAKERS TOO.
CLAY, I HAVE TO SAY, I AM BOTH
SADDENED AND NOT SURPRISED THAT
THIS IS WHERE IT'S GOING.
GIVEN CHINA'S INFLUENCE NOW IN
AMERICAN COMMERCE, AND, OF
COURSE, WITH THE MONEY THAT THE
NBA IS MAKING OVER THERE IN
CHINA WITH FRANCHISE FEES.
BUT, MAN, THE NBA HAS A LOT
OF -- A LOT TO SAY ABOUT TRUMP
AND WHAT HE DOES.
BUT SEEMS LIKE THEY HAVE NO
SPINE WHEN IT COMES TO WHAT
HAPPENS IN CHINA.
>> DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THEY HAVE
NO SPINE, LAURA, THEY HAVE NO
WHEN IT COMES TO WHAT'S GOING ON
IN CHINA.
I BELIEVE THIS IS THE WORST WEEK
THAT ANY PRO SPORTS LEAGUE HAS
HAD IN MY LIFE.
I KNOW YOU COVER A LOT OF THIS.
THE NBA BANS THE WORD "OWNER"
BECAUSE THEY DECIDE IT'S
RACIALLY INCENSE TIFF.
THEY REPLACED IT IRONICALLY
ENOUGH WITH THE WORD "GOVERNOR"
THAT HAS WORSE CONNOTATIONS IN
SOME STATES GIVEN THE WAY THINGS
HAVE GONE.
THEY ALSO DECIDE THEY'RE GOING
TO PULL THEIR ALL-STAR GAME OUT
OF CHARLOTTE, NORTH CAROLINA
BECAUSE OF A LOCAL STATE
TRANSGENDER BATHROOM LAW.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU, LAURA,
BUT I DON'T THINK TRANSGENDER
PEOPLE HAVE A LOT OF RIGHTS IN
CHINA JUST LIKE THE ENTIRE
POPULATION OF 1.4 BILLION PEOPLE
DOES NOT HAVE A LOT OF RIGHTS
THERE.
STEVE KERR WAS ASKED WHETHER OR
NOT --
>> IT WAS EMBARRASSING.
>> AND HE WASN'T WILLING TO
ENDORSE DEMOCRACY.
HE SAID AMERICA AND CHINA ARE
BASICALLY THE SAME THING WHEN IT
COMES TO HUMAN RIGHTS WHICH IS
SO ABSURD.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE COULD BE
THINKING.
>> THE FACT THAT KERR COULD EVEN
APPROACH DRAWING A MORAL
EQUIVALENCY BETWEEN A COUNTRY
THAT HAS AT LEAST A MILLION
MUSLIMS AND THE EQUIVALENT OF
INTERNMENT CAMPS, THEY HAVE NO
FREEDOM, CAN'T MOVE, POLITICAL
DISSIDENTS NEVER HEARD FROM
AGAIN, CHRISTIANS PERSECUTED.
EVERY MANNER OF OPPRESSION AND
SUBJUGATION.
THAT'S A GRAY AREA FOR MR. KERR
BECAUSE AL MIGHTY DOLLAR IS
INVOLVED.
THIS IS WHAT I'M SAYING.
WHEN THESE PEOPLE CLAIM THEY
CARE ABOUT ALL OF THESE SOCIAL
JUSTICE ISSUES AND THEY GET ALL
OFFENDED WHEN SOMEONE EVEN MIXES
CRITICISM AT HOME.
I'M CALLING THEM ON ALL OF THEIR
YOU KNOW WHAT.
I THINK THEY CARE ABOUT ONE
THING PRIMARILY.
THEY WANT TO WIN, BUT IT'S ABOUT
MONEY.
LET'S SAY IT'S ABOUT MONEY.
THEN WE ALL KNOW WHERE WE'RE
COMING FROM NOW.
IT'S ABOUT MONEY.
SO JUST LOSE THE IDEA THAT
YOU'RE ALL ABOUT YOUR MORAL
PRINCIPLES.
GIVE ME A BREAK.
THE WHOLE THING IS RIDICULOUS.
AND ANOTHER AMERICAN COMPANY, BY
THE WAY, CLAY, IS NOW CAVING IN
TO THE COMMUNIST CHINESE.
THE ROCKETS' MERCHANDISE
REPORTEDLY DISAPPEARED OFF OF
THE SHELVES OF NIKE STORES IN
CHINA.
MANAGERS OF FIVE NIKE STORES IN
BEIJING AND SHANGHAI SAY THEY'VE
BEEN TOLD THAT ALL ROCKETS
MERCHANDISE HAD TO BE REMOVED.
NOW, THIS IS THE SAME COMPANY,
BY THE WAY, THAT USES COLIN
KAEPERNICK TO REPRESENT THEM.
SO MAYBE THE NEW SLOGAN FOR
NIKE, CLAY, SHOULD BE, BELIEVE
IN SOMETHING AS LONG AS BEIJING
APPROVES.
>> OH, I MEAN --
>> WE COULD BRAND IT FOR THEM.
>> IT'S FANTASTIC.
THE IRONY ON THIS IS MIND
BLOWING, AGAIN, THESE GUYS HAVE
SAID OVER AND OVER AGAIN, LeBRON
JAMES IS TRYING TO MARKET
HIMSELF AS THE MUHAMMED ALU OF
HIS GENERATION.
MORE POWER TO HIM FOR MARKETING
PURPOSES, BUT MUHAMMED ALI WENT
TO PRISON AND FOUGHT AGAINST A
WAR.
LeBRON JAMES, IF HE REALLY
WANTED TO TAKE A STAND, COULD,
RIGHT?
HE COULD SAY I BELIEVE THAT THE
1.4 BILLION PEOPLE IN CHINA
DESERVE THE EXACT SAME RIGHTS
THAT MANY AMERICANS TAKE FOR
GRANTED -- FREEDOM OF SPEECH,
FREEDOM TO GET ON THE INTERNET
WITHOUT CENSORSHIP, ALL OF THESE
ISSUES.
I THINK A BIG PART OF THIS
GROWING AND GOING FORWARD, CHINA
IS MOVING -- THIS IS
IMPORTANT -- FROM, HEY, IF YOU
WANT TO PLAY THE AVENGERS MOVIE
IN OUR COUNTRY, WE'RE GOING TO
EDIT TWO MINUTES OF IT, IT'S FOR
INSIDE OF OUR COUNTRY.
WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO DO NOW IS
TRYING TO PROPAGATE THEIR
COMMUNIST WORLD VIEW INTO
AMERICA AND USING THE SPORTS
LEAGUES LIKE THE NBA AS A
CONDUIT TO DO IT AND THE NBA IS
ALLOWING THEM TO DO IT.
IT'S PATHETIC THAT THIS IS
ALLOWED TO BE TAKEN PLACE.
>> IT'S LIKE THEY GOT RID OF THE
NOMENCLATURE "OWNERS" FOR THE
OWNERS OF THE TEAM.
BUT THEY TRANSFER THAT OWNERSHIP
TO A COMMUNIST REGIME.
SO THE OWNERS NOW ARE FAR AWAY
IN BEIJING WHOSE TENTACLES REACH
RIGHT ACROSS THE OCEAN TO THE
UNITED STATES AND TO THE PSYCHE
AND MINDSET, APPARENTLY, OF
THESE PLAYERS.
BUT I'M GLAD THIS HAS ALL BEEN
REVEAL TOIR FOR US.